so as an example i just had a press
meeting in san francisco
from uh noon to one
and okay cool but i forgot to put in the
travel time to get from here to there
and to get from there back
so on my calendar i just put twelve to
one or no i didn't even do it i was sent
an invitation right so you just click
this i just clicked it and accepted it
okay cool right no trouble the person
who's sending me the
the calendar invite doesn't know that i
need travel time to get there to there
so
something should have prompted me to say
okay when you click accept
now do you have travel time that you
need to enter around this thing because
i just clicked accept and moved on to
the next thing or it could have been
intelligent enough to know by location
yeah where you are and then be able to
do that
buffers buffers should really be
automatic right because again no
starting destination we know ending
destination right and so we should be
able to say to you this one hour meeting
is really going to cost you an hour and
a half
right because we're allocating 15
minutes to get there and 15 minutes to
get back so in theory you're not free
and one you're free at 1 15 130. right
right so buffers are something that uh
you know microsoft calendar doesn't
handle
no calendar handles
so if they're a way to prompt for
buffers because they're absolutely there
aren't always buffers sometimes you know
phone calls and it's fine that it's
back-to-back absolutely yeah so
that would be a help to
prompt people to put buffers in
the other big calendar thing are the
things that are rolling yeah okay the
other big calendar issue i see is the
difference between my personal calendar
my family calendar my work counselor
yeah right so you have all these
different calendars to manage and my
wife has things that she puts on her
calendar that i don't know about and
so sinking calendars i don't know that
that's in your domain but you know it is
an issue with talent
so here's another thing that may be
unique to me because i'm a bi-coastal
kind of
i live in boston and i work in mountain
view so i'm on either coast
um i get
invitations to
conferences and events and parties and
meetups and
all kinds of stuff all the time and i
usually say no because i don't know if
i'm going to be there or not which coast
i'm going to be on or which city i'm
going to be in so
it's too much work to
unless it's really really important to
me i'm not going to go to the effort of
finding out okay am i going to be in
that city on this day
of the month and if i am okay i'll say
yes right so wouldn't it be cool if uh
my calendar knows you know generally
where i'm going to be
and it takes all these events
like events that maybe i'm not even
invited to just like there's a seminar
at stanford
tomorrow night oh i'm going to be in
town tomorrow night oh i could i could
do that
because i generally say no because
either i don't know about it or i do
know about it but i don't know if i'm
going to be in that place at that time
so i just say no
so i'd like to have a shadow calendar
that says here's my calendar that i'm
committed to and here's a shadow
calendar that overlays and says here's
other options for you you could choose
this and you can take a step